patrice un artiste qu'on ne connaît
certainement pas de nom mais dont on
connaît le travail seulement ses marques
en chine
vijay multi instrumentiste anglais c'est
lui qui a réalisé qu un domaine qui vont
dire que c'est l'idéateur de l'album
back to black d'amy winehouse son chevet
absolument un bon travail avec plein de
gens ils réalisent la bonne pour rufus
wainwright pour brandon j'en passe
il chante pas mais six ans durant jean
louis fait de louis donc dj
multistandard est allé plus exactement
absolument on écoute ce lot impossible
de résister à cette chance
donc c'est le premier extrait de cet
album pop corns belles choses et obtint
le funk avec dit l'oms
ça fait peut-être qu'on sait du earth
wind and fire chic
oui mais oui les travaux inspirés par le
son monte en quelques mois il est oxydé
davantage par le bit le rythme que l'ami
le dis donc je suis enchantée je suis
complètement enchanté seront les coûts
de notre action dont on pense à autre
chose pour décider parce que c'est comme
un dirigeant
il ya de tout
j'adore j'adore mark ronson y en a qui
vont dire les mauvaises langues
il rêve entrer on s'en fout honnêtement
c'est trop bon code tout fait danser oui
ça m'a fait mal rasé tire le coyote
oui la musique ici de sherbrooke c'est
un pseudonyme
c'est le pseudonyme de benoît qu'il est
qui lui est un digne héritier est un fan
de neil young vient de lancer on y voir
nombreux
ok rien de moins le volant ce nouveau
disque panorama eupen experts
donc évidemment c'est sa boîte d'abord
qui accroche l'oreille il faut il faut
il faut se garder ou non mais fou c'est
une belle plume qui dit des choses comme
ton quart est un si beau pays
le mien est une maison mobile toucher du
bois pour sculpter l'espoir laisse-moi
mettre de l'essence dans ton teint cas
méfiance à l'eau
c'est de toute beauté allô allô c'est le
coyote panorama à prendre les choses à
la semaine prochaine sa sélection
l'autre explication
à
non
général 1
partant